[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
niedrige Sirin schönen guten Abend in
allen Rudi Cerne heute mit einer
Extraportion Wintersport gegangen hallo
schönen guten Abend und wir blicken auf
die sie Themen an diesem Mittwoch
Sorge um Benedikt den 16 der
Gesundheitszustand des 95-jährigen hat
sich rapide verschlechtert Papst
franziskus ruft zu gebeten für seinen
Vorgänger auf
in ständiger Bereitschaft an der Grenze
zu Belarus begleitet unsere Reporterin
ukrainische Truppen die sich auf
mögliche Angriffe vorbereiten
und ohne Öl aus Russland die große
Raffinerie im brandenburgischen Schwedt
verarbeitet ab Januar nur noch Rohöl aus
anderen Quellen
[Musik]
er leitete die katholische Kirche als
erster deutscher seit Jahrhunderten
Papst Benedikt der 16 laut Vatikan hat
sich seinen Gesundheitszustand in den
vergangenen Stunden erheblich
verschlechtert in seiner Generalaudienz
am Morgen sagte Papst franziskus sein
Vorgänger sei sehr krank und rief zu
einem besonderen Gebet für ihn auf im
Anschluss besuchte er den 95-jährigen an
seinem Ruhesitz im Vatikan benedikt der
16 führte die katholische Kirche von
2005 bis 2013 bevor er aus
gesundheitlichen Gründen zurücktragen
gehen wir nach Rom zu unserer Kollegin
Annette hilsenbeck Annette was weiß man
denn über den Gesundheitszustand des
imitierten Papstes
nun den letzten Hinweis gab es von Papst
franziskus nachdem er Benedikt in
Kloster Marta eclesia besucht hatte
erforderte danach auf Twitter die
Gläubigen erneut auf für Benedikt zu
beten und so hieß es bis zum Ende zu
begleiten am Nachmittag am Mittag hatte
die Pressestelle des Vatikan erklärt
dass der Gesundheitszustand des
95-jährigen
nach einigen Stunden sich verschlechtert
habe er habe sich inzwischen
stabilisiert und er werde medizinisch
permanent überprüft die italienische
Nachrichtenagentur Ansa spricht davon
dass Benedikt bereits während der
Weihnachtstage zunehmend Atemprobleme
hatte er hatte ja ohnehin in den letzten
Monaten einen körperlich schwachen
Zustand geistig allerdings die ganze
Zeit als fit
danke für diese Informationen live aus
Rom Annette hilsenbeck jetzt in die
Ukraine Präsident selensky hat in einer
Rede im Parlament über den Wiederaufbau
des Landes gesprochen es werde das
größte Wirtschaftsprojekt Europas dazu
würden Unternehmer und Investoren
verstärkt gebraucht aber noch herrscht
Krieg im Land bedrohlich ist auch die
Lage an der Grenze zu Belarus zu Beginn
brachen hier ganz in der Nähe des 1.100
Dorfes niebrowski schon einmal russische
Truppen durch jetzt steht die Region
wieder im Fokus eines möglichen
feindlichen Aufmarsches eine Brüder
berichtet
vorbei an Panzersperren geht es Richtung
Niemandsland
anton ist Soldat der Grenztruppen und
nimmt uns mit an die belarussische
Grenze
am Posten angekommen zeigt er uns die
Brücke über den Fluss niepro sie haben
sie selbst gesprengt gleich zu Anfang
des Kriegs
unsere wichtigste Aufgabe ist die
Verteidigung der Staatsgrenze damit kein
Feind unsere Grenze Übertritt
die Soldaten sind vorsichtig wir dürfen
nicht alles zeigen aus
Sicherheitsgründen sagen sie
schon einmal gleich zu Beginn des Kriegs
lief der russische Angriff auf die
Ukraine über Belarus ukrainische
Grenzsoldaten hier an diesem Posten
gehörten zu den ersten Verletzten dieses
Krieges diesmal will die Ukraine besser
vorbereitet sein
das Dorf nebrowska liegt nur gut zwei
Kilometer von der Grenze entfernt die
Menschen hier durchaus beunruhigt
es gibt ständig den Knall von
Explosionen wie oft einmal alle paar
Tage höre ich das
irgendwelche seltsamen
explosionens Pantoffel sie haben schon
alles abgemacht warten nur noch auf den
passenden Zeitpunkt
schützen Gräben im Wald seit
Kriegsbeginn die Realität der
Grenztruppen
sich unsere Soldaten Licht gibt es hier
nicht aber so sind jetzt die Umstände
bis zu minus 30 Grad wird es hier kalt
es wird wohl ein langer und unbequemer
Winter
dieses Jahr wird aufgrund des Krieges
auch als das Jahr der rekordgaspreise in
die Geschichte eingehen und es wird nach
Einschätzung von Wirtschaftsminister
Habeck auch erst einmal teuer bleiben
das Jahr über werden wir höhere Preise
noch aushalten müssen so der grüne
Politiker mit Blick auf 200 23 Ende 2023
sein die Preise hoffentlich schon besser
wenn ich auch auf dem Niveau von 2021
kein russisches Rohöl nach Deutschland
das hatte die Bundesregierung
entschieden noch bevor russlands
Präsident Putin gestern Ölexporte unter
anderem nach Deutschland verboten hat
besonders betroffen von der Entscheidung
der Bundesregierung ist die PCK
Raffinerie im brandenburgischen Schwedt
hier werden etwa 95% des Treibstoffs für
Berlin und Brandenburg produziert vor
allem mit russischem Rohöl über die
Pipeline duschbar darauf soll ab 1
Januar verzichtet werden und jetzt
befürchten die Menschen Preiserhöhungen
mehr von Jan Meyer
die rund 30.000 Bewohner von Schwedt
blicken mit gemischten Gefühlen auf die
Zukunft des größten Arbeitgebers ihrer
Stadt das ist ja nicht nur das PCK da
hängen ja noch viele andere kleine
Betriebe dran die sich dort angesiedelt
haben also ich sehe es mir Sorge ich
finde es wichtig auch mal neue Wege
auszuprobieren ja man wird sehen was
dann kommt fast 60 Jahre hat die
Raffinerie russisches Erdöl verarbeitet
ab Neujahr wird PCK auf anderen Wegen
beliefert die Raffinerie wird ab Januar
über Rostock versorgt da sind die
Schiffe bestellt und zusätzliche Mengen
kommen über Polen so dass wir auch im
Januar von der Auslastung von 70%
ausgehen und die werden im Laufe des
Jahres dann weiter erhöhen wollen
Tankschiffe vor allem aus Übersee Decken
über den Hafen von Rostock und eine
Pipeline immerhin 55% des rohölbedarfs
der Raffinerie Polen liefert ab
Jahresbeginn aus Danzig 15%. weitere 15%
könnten hinzukommen wenn Kasachstan
durch die russische drohspannleitung
liefert russisches Erdöl auf einen
Schlag komplett zu ersetzen das ist aus
Sicht von Experten ein riskanter Plan es
ist unklar ob wir mit dem Verzicht auf
russisches Pipeline Öl
mehr russlandschaden oder uns selbst
mehr Schaden dadurch dass nicht genügend
Benzin und Diesel in Ostdeutschland
produziert werden kann dadurch dass
möglicherweise
Kurzarbeit in der Raffinerie Schwedt
entsteht doch weiter Erdöl aus Russland
zu beziehen das lehnt die
Bundesregierung ab bis Ende Januar sind
Lieferverträge für nicht russisches Öl
schon fest vereinbart eine ganze Stadt
hofft dass es auch darüber hinaus eine
Zukunft für Schwedt gibt
die gesetzliche Rentenversicherung
erwartet zum Jahresende einen Überschuss
die Präsidentin der Rentenversicherung
Rosbach geht von einem Plus von 2,1
Milliarden Euro aus vor einem Jahr noch
habe man ein Defizit von mehr als 6
Milliarden befürchtet es gäbe aber immer
mehr Menschen die Beiträge einzahlten
außerdem habe die corona-pandemie zu
einem Anstieg der Sterblichkeit gerade
bei älteren Menschen geführt
nach immer neuen Einschränkungen für
Frauen in Afghanistan hat der
UN-Sicherheitsrat die Herrschenden
Taliban dazu aufgerufen die
Menschenrechte zu achten die Machthaber
hatten am Wochenende eine Arbeitsverbot
für MitarbeiterInnen von nicht
Regierungsorganisationen entlassen
deswegen setzen mehrere NGOs ihre
Programme aus ebenso das
Bundesentwicklungsministerium das stellt
jetzt weitere Hilfen für Afghanistan auf
den Prüfstand
wir schauen auf den Balkan dort
schaukelt sich der Konflikt zwischen
Kosovo und Serbien weiter hoch Kosovo
hat heute morgen den größten
Grenzübergang zu Serbien geschlossen
zuvor hatten Demonstranten auf der
serbischen Seite die Zufahrt zu dem
Übergang blockiert die serbische
Regierung erkennt das Kosovo seit Jahren
als Staat nicht an und unterstützt
militante Serben im Norden des Landes
lange wurde über dieses Gesetz
gestritten das lieferkettengesetz das
mit dem neuen Jahr in Kraft tritt es
betrifft größere Firmen und die müssen
künftig sehr genau hinschauen ob bei der
Produktion von Waren im Ausland die
Menschenrechte eingehalten werden
konkret geht es um Themen wie
Kinderarbeit Arbeitsschutz oder
Sklaverei mehr von Christoph Schneider
in Indien bauen Kinder unter Menschen
und würdigen Bedingungen Mika ab ein
natürliches Mineral das in
Kosmetikprodukten für den besonderen
Glanz sorgt nur ein Beispiel dafür warum
ab Januar das deutsche
lieferkettengesetz in Kraft tritt es
verlangt das Firmen bei Lieferanten
darauf achten dass Menschenrechte und
Umweltschutz Regeln eingehalten werden
Kinderarbeit soll verhindert werden
das lieferkettengesetz gilt zunächst nur
für Firmen mit mehr als 3000
Beschäftigten ab 2024 dann für Firmen
mit mehr als 1000 Beschäftigten die
Sorgfaltspflicht der Unternehmen
erstreckt sich auf die gesamte
Lieferkette vom Rohstoff bis zum
fertigen Verkaufsprodukt allerdings
abhängig davon wie viel Einfluss das
Unternehmen tatsächlich hat bei
Verstößen müssen Unternehmen tätig
werden viel zu bürokratisch sagen die
Arbeitgeber
wie soll ein Mittelständler aus dem
Sauerland wissen ob das Kupfer Teil dass
er in seine Maschine einbaut aus einer
Mine in der Kupfer gewonnen wird kommt
die allen menschenrechtlichen
Anforderungen genügt wir können das
nicht leisten die Regierung hält das
dagegen für machbar das was wir jetzt
gesetzlich einfordern das gibt es
bereits schon als empfehlungsform und
insoweit Betten wir das ein in eine
gesetzliche Regelung und übersetzen das
in gesetzliche Anforderungen die für
alle für alle Unternehmen gleichermaßen
verständlich ist gut 900 Unternehmen
hierzulande müssen lieferkettengesetz
zunächst umsetzen
jetzt weiter mit dem Sport jede Menge
wintersportstand und steht heute auf dem
Programm Rudi das volle Paket Biathlon
läuft ja noch auf Schalke und in
Oberstdorf fand die Qualifikation für
den ersten Wettkampf der
Vierschanzentournee statt und da
überzeugte der Norweger Halver igna
graneröd mit der Bestweite auf der
Schattenbergschanze als bester Deutscher
landete Karl Geiger auf Platz 7
der Lokalmatador von Oberstdorf
karl-geiger zeigt vor 16.000
begeisterten Zuschauern einen soliden
Sprung auf 129 einhalb Meter sie
wirklich jedem Sprunger Stücke besser
werden
und dann am Ende wird abgerechnet
ebenfalls in guter Form präsentiert sich
Andreas Wellinger als Achter mit einer
Weite von 130 Metern insgesamt
qualifizieren sich alle sieben deutschen
Springer für den Wettkampf morgen ganz
vorne aber heute der Norweger
er landet bei 133 einhalb Metern der
Weltcup Gesamtführende und top Favorit
aus Polen David Kubatzki
und die Österreicherin eva pinkelnick
hat das Auftaktspringen der Silvester
Tournee in Villach gewonnen und damit
die gesamtweltcup-führung übernommen die
beste deutsche Selina Freitag erreichte
in der Alpenarena trotz leicht verpatzte
Landung im zweiten Durchgang noch Rang 7
[Musik]
die Olympia II Katharina Althaus schob
sich von Platz 16 noch auf neun vor und
hat die Chance auf den Gesamtweltcupsieg
gewahrt
ja das und mehr vom Wintersport auch
morgen wieder bei uns in Sportstudio
live von 11:15 Uhr an
dart-profi Gabriel Clemens hat nach
einem wahren Krimi im legendären
Londoner Ally palley das WM Achtelfinale
erreicht sein walisischer Gegner Jim
Williams hatte sich bei drei zu zwei
satzführungen bereits einen matchstart
erspielt doch sein Wurf in die Doppel 6
misslang
so konnte der Saarländer Clemens die
Partie dank eines perfekten letzten
Wurfs direkt ins Bullseye noch mit 4:3
gewinnen
ein Volltreffer gleich auch wieder beim
Biathlon danke schön Rudi wir haben
jetzt noch die gewinnzahlen vom
Mittwochslotto und die gehen so vier 14
17 27 29 42 und die Superzahl lautet 3
weitere Gewinnzahlen auf lotto.zdf.de
und auf der ZDF Textseite 557
regnerische windige und milde Aussichten
hat gleich Katja horneffer für Sie um 21
Uhr meldet sich wolfsschmiese mit dem
heute-journal so viel von uns schönen
Dank schönen Abend und gerne bis morgen
[Musik]
guten Abend heute Nacht regnet es oft in
Deutschland nur hier in Bayern und in
Sachsen bleibt es bei Südwestwind wohl
trocken hier in Niederbayern ist es zum
Teil auch klar dort sinken die
Temperaturen bis minus zwei Grad sonst
sind es in Bayern 3 bis 0 im übrigen
Deutschlands 10 bis 6 Grad die
Höchsttemperaturen morgen liegen hier im
östlichen Bayern bei 6 Grad sonst werden
9 bis 14 Grad erreicht und auch morgen
regnet es oft im Westen gibt's dazu auch
kräftige Schauer am ehesten trocken
bleibt es hier im Osten und eben Süden
Deutschlands bei Südwestwind an diesem
Wetter ändert sich auch am Freitag wenig
am Silvestertag wird es im Norden
stürmisch und am Oberrhein ungewöhnlich
mit guten Abend